kate en france quinze ans après le début
de la sphère grigori les avocates des
grands parents de l'enfant assassiné en
l'intention de demander un complément
d'enquêté avec l'utilisation de tests
adn sur les timbres poste des lettres du
corbeau dont l'une revendiquer
clairement le meurtre de grégory
l'utilisation de ces nouvelles
techniques ultra sophistiqué
si elle est acceptée par le juge cette
utilisation pose un certain nombre de
questions tirées kurt et la vérité de la
sphère grégory se cache peut être
derrière ce timbre cette lettre
menaçante envoyé au grand père de
l'enfant porte l'identité du corbeau
dans l'adn de la salive qui en coller le
petit carré de papier pour les
scientifiques les obstacles à
l'identification ne sont pas
insurmontables 17 ans après mais il ya
tout de même certaines conditions nous
avons du recul avec des échantillons qui
sont différents qui avait plusieurs
années près de dix ans et qui nous en
donner son permis d'avoir des résultats
avec succès mais nous avons déjà
travaillé sur des échantillons
- âgées pour lesquelles nous n'avons pas
pu obtenir de résultats certains membres
de la famille avait gardé enfoui au fond
de leur mémoire cette pièce à conviction
c'est une affaire marseillaise du même
type résolu grâce à une analyse de
salive 14 ans après qui a fait renaître
le fol espoir
cette décision est une décision
réfléchie
il n'est dirigé contre personne ne
voudrait pas qu'il y ait la moindre
équivoque là dessus nous sommes au
service de la vérité
et tant qu'il restera un espoir de voir
confondre à travers le corbeau
l'assassin du petit grégory serait
criminel de ne pas intenter pour
christine et jean marie villemin coupé
aujourd'hui du reste de leur famille et
c'est une nouvelle épreuve
ils redoutent par dessus tout le réveil
des passions et des haines suscité par
la faire et ne veulent surtout pas de
nouvelles polémiques mais leurs avocats
la firme s'ils vont la certitude
scientifique que les résultats seront
indiscutable alors ils se soumettent on
ose analyse tout à fait d'accord et
toutes les mesures permettant d'avancer
sur le chemin la vérité
plusieurs christian première question
faisabilité deux expertises adn est ce
que nous avons le support est ce que les
scellés sont encore en bon état un
scientifique pourra répondre à ses
questions et nous le dira
les époux villemin pose une autre
condition que les tests concernent tous
les protagonistes de la sphère même ceux
aujourd'hui décédé les deux partis ont
peu la même demande auprès de la cour
d'appel de dijon
c'est donc elle qui décidera ou non de
la réouverture du dossier